Hi, I'm Chris Nesladek,
and I'm speaking
at Google I/O this year.
The topic of my presentation
is entitled
"How to Marry Interaction and
Visual Design the Android Way."
We've been really busy
working on Cupcake this year,
and our UI guidelines aren't
quite ready for distribution.
However,
if you come to this talk,
you'll learn
how to think like a designer,
not to mention
learn how to use
the templates,
assets, and behaviors
that we built
into the new framework.
So how are you going
to learn to be a designer?
Well, I'm going to teach you
the three pillars
of interaction design:
you're going to learn
about structure,
about behavior,
and you're going to learn
a little bit about expression.
Let's take a look
at an example.
Here in the new Gmail,
the structure
is fairly established
where you can see that you
can select a message,
view that message,
or star it.
Now, if I actually choose
to select a message,
the behavior that's
associated with that
by tapping the check box
is a button bar.
It comes up from the bottom
and allows the user
the ability to archive,
label, or delete
the messages
they have chosen.
What ties this all together
is the expression layer.
The expression layer
tells me
that the three zones that
I've established as a designer
are available
to a user
through the use
of check boxes,
a standard list view
button element,
as well as
a "Favorites" star.
I hope you'll join me
May 27th and 28th
in San Francisco
where you'll learn
to be a designer,
just like this.
Well...at least for a day.